I gave Biden money because when he went in front of these coal miners and told
them that I know how to shovel coal, you can learn how to program a computer.
I'm like, I need a year of this. He literally did the learn to code me.
Finding that there is an undercurrent of support for Trump.
Now that did not exist last time that suddenly this thing has gone. So bananas,
everything we've been talking about for this half hour,
that now there's people that would have never considered voting for Trump.
The first time that basically still see the wheels on the machines still see
some level of pride in America,
still see paychecks that are working on unemployment.
That's low in black unemployment. That's low in Hispanic, unemployment that low.
And they like getting rid of some of the regulation and all of those things that
were not an extra Wars.
And he's trying to get us out of Afghanistan and everything else that suddenly
people that would have been completely, um,
in opposition to Trump last time.
I think a lot of their,
I think a lot of them are just going to be happy to stay home.
They're going to be like, look, I can't bring myself to vote for this guy. He's,
you know, we can think of all the names, but I'm not going to endorse this. Uh,
especially if Biden is the nominee,
I gave Biden money because when he went in front of these coal miners and tell
them, I know how to shovel coal, you can learn how to program a computer.
I'm like, I need a year of this.
We literally did the learn to code me. I mean, for those people then,
for people that know about this meeting, this was a meme that when, what was it?
Was it Buzzfeed when Buzzfeed was going to use basically.
Laid off a lot of journalists and, and they're all boo-hooing. Um,
and then all the trolls and the, I use the word trolls in the good sense,
just added them hashtag learn to code. And people got kicked off.
Twitter, meaning learn how to do something productive.
Instead of being a Buzzfeed and bright and Biden actually brought it to life.
He also brought to life. It's an audience where it's not accurate, right? It is.
If you know how to write from Buzzfeed,
you could probably have the technical skills to learn how to code on a basic
level. If you're a coal miner that does not mean,
you know how to use a computer, well, this is not. And by the way,
if you're a computer programmer, you can't mind coal either.
These do not transition very easily. So, uh,
I think it was comfortably smug who tweeted out that you do know if there's the
debates.
Trump is going to bring that stripper and put her in the front row and ask Joe,
if he's met his granddaughter and it's going to be just complete chaos.
So I hope he's the nominee very desperately, but watching.
Him is sort of depressing. Right? I know. So I know this is where you wouldn't,
it's depressing in that for,
for someone that's a little more old school politics and not on the fringe of
the new, right. But for someone that like, you know,
I want the system to somehow function, even though I always tell you, it's like,
I love all the intellectual adventures. I go under the you, I really do.
But for someone that wants like some thing to kind of hold,
that was somewhat centrist. And we could have an interesting, no,
but he can't do it anymore. It seems like he can't do it.
Which is why he's telling these guys to code.
It's why he's saying you can pick your gender depending on which jail you want
to go to. Yeah. And you didn't at the equality forum.
It's not what birth sex you are.
It's what you identify as you're gonna have an awful lot of male rapists in
women's prisons.
He literally said that he was brought in as the same guy and he can't be sane.
But I think that gets to your point that this thing just eats through
everything.
Yeah. Right. And I, he, again, he doesn't have that space within his party. Uh,
I can't believe he said that about the jails. I mean, this is hilarious.
I am not making it up. How are you, how are you.
Not, how is this depressing to you? This is glorious. I can just.
You know what I'm telling my guys right now,
we're going to we'll play the clip right.
In prison.
The determination should be that your sexual identity is
defined by what you say. It is not what in fact the prison says it is.
And in that case, you should be entitled also to OGB wine. Anyway,
you didn't ask that question because you're not likely to either.
Well, there you go, malice.
That's the man that you want to be the democratic candidate for press.
Desperately. Um,
one of the things that this speaks to is one of the best aspects of
conservatism, which is asking questions, like, what do you,
when you're advocating for program,
what do you do with the people who use this program in bad faith or this law in
bad faith.
And very often people on the left don't have an answer or they'll hand wave it
away. Like, Oh, there won't be that many cases. Well, that don't, we,
that many cases again is Nicholas Cruz in Florida shooting up a school.
It's that outlier that both moves culture and also is the destroyer.
And that is who we should be concerned about.
What else are you tracking right now? Um, what,
what else is on your mind out of the th that's unearthed in the bottom of the.
Well, I've been, so I've been engaging in like PSYOPs with a lot of these types.
So for example, when you're working on a campaign,
you're going to have tunnel vision bunk. You're going,
you're living in a bunker, right?
So when there's an article that comes out in the New York times, everyone,
that campaign is freaking out, how is this going to play?
How the other campaigns you, you kind of have, it's like, Plato's cave,
very limited information.
So what I do is I have a bigger Twitter following than many of these campaign
managers for these candidates.
So instead people tweet like nasty things at them.
That'll strengthen their resolve. If you're saying, Oh, Warren's this and that,
it's like, yeah, I'm fighting for her against you. So I will be like, Hey,
at Roger Lau, latest polls came out from Iowa.
Five of the six candidates have solidified their support.
Only Warren has lost support.
How depressed are you at the campaign on a scale of one's Anthony Bordain.
And then that gets retweeted. And you know,
it's filling up as notifications and he's already having a bad day and now he's
going to be freaking out even more, hopefully.
So you're, instead of killing them with, uh, attacks, it's not quite kindness,
you're killing them, but you're killing. You're killing them with sarcasm.
Basically.
Sarcasm is a sincere question. I mean, I'm,
I'm giving the devil on their left shoulder steroids and being like more
insecurity, more fear, more freaking out and just ginning up that kind of,
I mean,
I can't imagine working in campaign is in a state of constant stress and panic,
and you're putting out fires all the time. So let's add some and watch it burn.
How.
Concerned are you that the,
at the social media level and at the big tech level that the game has been so
rigged and manipulated already that we have no idea what's going on. I,
you know, I keep mentioning this thing about, uh,
shadow banning is now in Twitter's terms of service,
they can literally throttle accounts. We've,
we've known that they've been doing it forever,
but now they're telling us they're doing it as of January 1st.
And we all just keep playing the game as if the game is not being.
But the game is always going to be rigged. I mean,
when you have your enemies to expect them to play fair is extremely naive.
This is my Soviet mindset talking. Uh,
we did have a president who tweeted his way into the white house.
And I think what people don't appreciate is the existential angst.
It causes someone who works at a social media company to see their product or
their program being from their perspective,
subverted by those who they despise to further their agenda.
This must cause them a lot of grief.
But doesn't, it also cause them to, you know,
tighten those spickets and make sure that as we get closer to the election,
that Michael malice isn't going to be heard as much,
or Trump's not going to be heard as much or, or Ruben or anybody else. I mean,
sure. I mean, th the thing we all pretend that that's not really, it,
like that would be the thing that we would all be relentlessly talking about.
Right. If we really were trying to change something here.
I think they are losing tools in their toolbox. Uh, and I think, I mean,
you know, Kamala Harris was calling for Trump to be banned from Twitter,
remember this? And she got pushed back even from the left.
And when she lost her campaign, I did a ham tasting on my live stream.
And we tried, you know,
different kinds of hams from all over the world because the pig was finally
roasted. So I think they are going to try different tactics,
but because they're being called out on their tactics,
instead of being called out on the issues, this is why they're freaking out.
It used to be, they would say,
Dave Rubin's are racist and you would spend months being of, no, I'm not, no,
I'm not. Now it's Dave Rubin saying,
look at their technique of calling me, Rogan, everybody else,
a racist as a means of preemptively dismissing them.
So by you calling out their technique, it loses almost all its efficacy.
You know, it's funny because like three years ago,
let's say when daily beast or mother Jones or any of these awful things,
these, these G what do you call it? You call them jihadist.
Jihadis without the testosterone. Yes.
Whenever they were doing that. And they would call me all these things,
you know, I'd, I'd fight back. And then, you know,
I could occasionally get them to change one line or whatever,
but then they wouldn't, they wouldn't actually retweet the thing.
They would just change it and nobody's seen it and whatever it's out there,
it's out there for then right. Stealth edit.
So then Wikipedia can grab from it and right. And the rest of it.
But it used to really upset me, obviously when I first, you know,
like anyone that starts getting that heat, it,
it it's hot at first and in a weird way now, um,
because I have a book coming out in April and I know what that is going to cause
that, that microscope to look at me or, you know, uh,
really fine tune on me is that I'm glad that I went through it. Now,
do you find that too? That you've been through a lot of the,
the hits on this stuff and it's like, that actually makes you stronger now. Oh.
Especially if it makes my audience stronger. Cause they love it because,
because there's, it's like a greatest hits album, right? So it's xenophobic,
racist, homophobic, blah, blah, blah. I'm from Brooklyn. I'm an immigrant.
You know what I mean? So when they, I, uh, when I went after George Soros.
Oh, we visited. Can you talk? Yeah. Talk about this. Cause this is, uh,
this was, this is exactly why I think you're such a great thinker. Truly. What,
what this whole story?
Oh, it was beautiful. So, uh,
some guy from the Atlantic and I'm not trying to be dismissive.
I genuinely don't remember his name.
Um, it's pretty terrible. They've.
Been, but Dave, they were terrible since Woodrow Wilson.
Don't I mean, even before the nation, I mean,
these people were the ones agitating for world war one. I mean,
you have to go back. So, um, they,
there was Rudy Giuliani made a comment that he's more Jewish than George Soros.
Now, in any other context, if you were talking to Jewish people and said,
someone can be culturally Jewish without actually having Jewish ethnicity,
as opposed to someone could have Jewish ethnicity and basically be a total boy,
right? This is not controversial. This is very well known.
Everyone knows this. Obama kept saying he was the first Jewish president. Yeah.
This is very known. We were both Jewish.
We know people who are super Jewish and then people who were basically waspy and
the people who are adopted you is basically like the culture. Um,
and the guy from the Atlantic was like, Ugh, in the world of Trump,
someone can be less Jewish somebody else.
And he's saying this about a literal Holocaust survivor, right.
Referring to Soros. Yeah. But what was amazing is in the same way,
it's Dave Rubin, comma secret Klansmen and homophobe comma.
It's George Soros, comma literal Holocaust survivor.
Now I always say the corporate press is factual, but not truthful.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.